welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and Rick and Morty's vat of acid
episode taught us that if it comes to
throwing yourself an acid or dwelling on
countless lifetimes of suffering acid is
the way to go episode 8 was my favorite
of season 4 so far maybe because the way
it pays homage to my other favorite
animated sci-fi comedy Futurama
but in a very rick way and by rick i
think we always mean evil like we should
never ever feel bad for rick ever again
and i feel kind of stupid for ever
feeling bad for him because let's
explain this [ __ ] it opens with rick
forcing morty into a fake that of acid
to trick some gangsters they wait it out
in the safe liquid and release fake
bones to fake their deaths
dan harmon said this idea came from the
writers joking about how open bats of
acid and movies like Tim Burton's Batman
is kind of a really weird trope and past
Rick's plane guess Brandon Johnson
defended the trope as epic and cinematic
which a writers found to be hilarious
and Brandon Johnson who plays goldenfold
made the observation and it's just good
for production value like as if that's
why why so many people died in vats of
acid in the eighties it was an easy way
to kill people so like the writers Morty
hates this idea he thinks it's stupid he
bails on it and he argues with Rick over
the value of their respective ideas Rick
prefers dumb deadly adventures like
pickle rick morty prefers fantasy
escapist adventures like the recent game
of thrones episode that ended up being
all about six dragons and yeah pit day
totally got in on that Game of Thrones
fever right Rick indulges Morty and
gives him a story devices he's always
wanted a time reset button that allows
Morty to save his place kind of like in
a video game and loop back to it a
device that lets save your place like in
a video game but in real life so that
you can try stuff and then go back to
your save point yes Morty I saw it on
Futurama is Futurama he's actually
referring to the 2013 final episode of
Futurama season 7 episode 13 an episode
titled meanwhile now if you haven't seen
it yet and you want to watch it but you
should it's a great show skip to this
time to avoid spoilers okay in the
Futurama finale
fry steals Farnsworth's time button to
loop back every ten seconds so that he
can steal diamonds and propose to Leela
he arranges for Leela to meet him at the
top of ability to give her answer but
she's late so he assumes she rejected
him and he jumps but it turns out she's
only late because of his dozens of
resets the ladies wrist
watch where I is forced to reset his
fall over and over again until the
others can figure out a way to cushion
his fall but he bounces and he breaks
the time button freezing time trapping
Fry and Leela in frozen time fortin's up
being a lifetime to grow old together
it's sweet and then at the end decades
later Farnsworth shows up in a time
portal and gives them a chance to reset
everything but with no memory of their
lives together and fry and Leela decide
to give it a go
end of series now Rick and Morty is a
very different Joe from Futurama
Futurama was an absurdist comedy with
futurist parodies of our current society
that typically didn't get too dark aside
from you know watching Fry's dogs slowly
die God
by comparison Rick and Morty has way
more of a cynical nihilistic agenda and
so Rick and Morty's take on a time-loop
episode explores the darkest
implications of that concept in the
episodes second act is a five-minute
montage that kind of like the opening
montage of Pixar's up explores Morty
falling in love struggling in love and
ending in a heartbreaking deadly
scenario and the writers revealed that
this sequence wasn't in the script it
was just a lovely piece of animated
storytelling conceived by the director
one of the biggest heroes of it as the
director because the episode was 5
minutes short on his own accord he just
did that whole extended playing crash
sequence that wasn't in the script
they said kind of go nuts and I read
that book alive in middle school it may
have traumatized me as a kid Morty makes
it through and things seem great but
Jerry's stupidity causes Morty sacrifice
to be for nothing and Morty like fry
ends up sitting on the time button and
dooming himself and it gets even darker
Rick reveals the whole experience was a
cruel trick just to make Morty hate the
idea of time resets if ant-man and the
wasp can do it I'm not interested in its
weird comment since episode 5 of the
season broke the ice on time travel
though I did love hearing Rick talk [ __ ]
about ant-man the wasp introducing
quantum realm time vortexes so the
Avengers could time travel an in-game
with this episode's co-writer Jeff loved
this being the guy who will write the
script for ant-man 3 anyway Rick shows
that each reset forced the horrible
murder of some other alternate universe
Morty much like The Prestige Chris
Nolan's magic movie in which spoiler
warning for that movie
the transporting man trick requires the
murder of a clone that's right you
little [ __ ]
it's the prestige you proceed did I kill
me Morty every time you recessed the
smells Jessica's hair every time you
relived a satisfying fart that's how
many more days you've incinerated you
greedy little chunky God the only way to
fix things is to condense all of these
realities so that this Morty has to live
with all the horrible consequences of
what he's done essentially Rick made
Morty like himself a sadistic monster
across the endless timelines twisted
live with the guilt of his actions feel
this this is God like Rick constantly on
the run from the Citadel in the
Federation whoever it is morning now has
to deal with hordes of haters trying to
force him to pay up and the only way to
escape from that miserable existence is
do you see - that is good that is good
kiss the vet remember this bat of acid
is fake it's a cheap painless escape
hatch it tricks your haters to stop
judging you to feel sympathy for your
suicide temporarily absolving you of
your sins but it requires no real
sacrifice or contrition from the sinner
and if you think about it brick has
already pulled this same trick on us
back in season two that darkening of the
autoerotic assimilation episode in which
Rick appears to nearly kill himself when
we saw that many of us saw Rick in a
different light we thought oh he's not
an [ __ ] he's just a damaged stuff
destructive enigma we have to reexamine
yeah we were like those dumb gangsters
in the opening scene spending way too
long over analyzing the self-destruction
what it means wait longer than Rick
anticipated us to do like it right this
is the show he just gives up and says
you know what screw you I'm just gonna
take shots at you now so what's the
difference between the time resetting
that Rick and Morty and the time reset
into Futurama
well this concept is so profound and
Futurama that it ends the series on this
beautiful hopeful grace note but this
concept is so mundane and Rick and Morty
that it's corrupted into this teaching
tool for
immortal characters to fake their
suicides to trick Supreme Court justices
into feeling bad for them yeah two great
animated sci-fi series just one with far
less hope for Humanity so what do we
thank legit or loose [ __ ]
I'm gonna discuss the ins and outs of
this episode with two buds who overthink
it as much as I do but first if you're
like me you probably start thinking
about what to eat for dinner while
you're eating lunch the previous day I
love food that's why I love using post
mates I'll oppose math even more right
now because I can get food delivered
without having to leave the house or
even opening the door
they created non-contact deliveries so
now when I order from local restaurants
everything is left right outside my door
they also have post mates pickup which I
have been using to order takeout for my
favorite local restaurants who
definitely need our support now more
than ever like there's a burrito place
around the corner
I'm just really glad that I can give
them some business with post mates and
post mates doesn't just deliver burgers
or sushi they can also make my life
easier in other ways by picking up
everything I need from Walgreens or
7-eleven
and dropping it off outside my door just
download post mates on iOS or Android
find your favorites and get everything
you want delivered within the hour and
for a limited time post mates is giving
our viewers and listeners $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days so
to start your three deliveries download
the app and use the code Rix planed
that's code Rix plain for one hundred
dollars of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days when you download the post
mates app anything you need anytime you
need it
post mate it and we are back joining me
to discuss the vat of acid episode of
Rick and Morty are my good buds Rick and
Morty superfans and I think versions of
me murdered an alternate timeline so
that I can get unless second chances
Tommy Bechtold and Sam basher hey fellas
how you doing thanks for having me and
Sam is a better version of me so I'm
like baby bear right in the middle all
right well let's start by breaking down
some of the numbers of this episode
Sam was nice enough to go through this
episode a few times to quantify each of
Morty's resets and giving us the
alternate implications for each of those
loops just to give us a sense of how big
this trauma is that Morty now has to
live with so Sam let's break down the
numbers what did you find
all right so in total I got technically
if you count when Rick kills Morty in
the beginning there's 19 but there are
18 total
I'm sets but after that there are a
total of 23 resets that we see on screen
and then 29 that I kind of have to count
for because like when we see Morty pull
a full GTA and start mowing people down
on the street we don't see the reset but
that happens so 23 total and 29
off-screen also a bunch of bonuses that
we can read off later which are
fantastic that we're able to see on the
screens as they go by but want me to run
him down
yeah let's do it all right first up we
get Morty in math class and there is one
reset first he pulls down mr.
goldenfold's pants and shows the class
his privates and then he resets so he
can start all over again
then we get Morty talking to Jessica
first time around he is really nervous
she walks away it doesn't care about him
then we get one more reset where he's
more confident and Jessica just came and
control herself next we get three resets
where Morty attempts to jump over a
manhole cover
first see folson second heat like
straddles it and third he makes it but
he does get hit by a car so the death
resets next yeah Morty orders the most
boring food at a restaurant of dinner
roll and mashed potatoes and recess for
Maine lobster is that Maine lobster I
thought he was just ordering two of them
he's like oh this is oh no I went two of
these dead girls that sounds pretty good
he seems like that kind of guy that's
just spicy enough for him after that he
does the thing that any 80s or 90s
coming-of-age story the trope it's him
trying to go into the locker room the
women's locker room he sets it he walks
in and gets chased out and then he
resets something he never did it
good call don't do that that's gross
next is my favorite petty one is where
he tries to beat a boss in a video game
in resets so that he have a perfect game
following that morty tries to sample
different ice creams and the ones i
wrote down where there was a green
flavor
which was either pistachio or apple
mango based on the menu then chocolate
which could have been Robbie Road which
is funny yeah vanilla or butterscotch
then Brenner mint or peppermint
I don't know I don't understand the joke
and then coffee so we get four on there
next we get suicide-by-cop more morty
attempting to throw a paper ball into
the trash and he misses in resets morty
steals a car he plays out GTA with his
heroin buddy and he runs down
pedestrians who are texting while
they're walking across the street then
we get more East Ealing a wheelchair
from an old man knocking him into the
street and coming back so that he can
actually help him be a good person next
I initially wrote down a lien or G slash
Cantina band but like this no it's
definitely an orgy there's someone
wearing like a mask there's like I don't
it looks like one big being I couldn't
know what I was I think it's
deliberately meant to be confusing what
exactly is coping I'm there but I love
it because it was just like a little
little pieces of kink that hurt all over
that one something for everybody
then we get Morty attempting to toss a
cheese puff into his mouth he hits his
lower lip then his eye then he fully
misses so eventually I think he got it I
don't know how many that was at least
three that we saw on screen then he
attempts the high dive and gets laughed
off for not actually jumping into the
pool which I thought we'd get a really
cool scene where he jumped in with the
remote and it messed up time but no
that's not the point then we get the
most important one where he resets to go
into the strip club but a hat meets the
love of his life and it accidentally
gets reset by Jerry so it's kind of
tough to call this one because it's not
Morty's fault
but following that is when he gets maced
twice in the face or three times excuse
me and there's two resets in there and
then after that he trips and falls on it
and he ends up resetting when she walks
away from which is three and then to cap
it off he resets three times to be
murdered by gorillas over and over and
over again and I'm counting maybe one
more just because the last shot we see
of him is jumping into the pit and being
ripped apart again and then it goes away
and for bonuses you got to throw it in
there there on the screens as they go by
I'm sure you mentioned it but Morty's
drinking some sort of beaker of
something and you see him melt for the
deleted timeline as well as him and Rick
ship for some reason him at the bed my
favorite is he's in a on the driveway
and he has a basketball next to me he's
melt on
which means that he kept missing a
three-pointer and he Jeff and lastly
they say that he even the even the other
times they mentioned without mentioning
what it is and it's clearly like must
have been like masturbating or something
like that he relived that over and over
again which is just it was it fits for
Morty but wow he he learned a valuable
lesson in this episode and Sam you
pointed out something interesting here
not only did he die of course doing the
mundane tricks of like trying to fit a
ball into a hole like the guy was also
like I had other suicides we didn't see
he drinks that potion which either means
he's just like trying it like he's
trying Rick's like mystery concoction or
like there was another example of a
different way tried to kill himself
which like to me just reminds me of the
the Groundhog Day thing right like
there's a suicide montage which resets
the loop but like it's implied that
there were endless different
incarnations of this which is super dark
oh yeah I wouldn't mind like a darker
like YouTube like animated short where
you see all the other timelines of the
Groundhog Day movie where you see all
the other outcomes of whatever happened
to that version of him which is just
awful yeah Groundhog Day is that crazy
scene where it's just like Chris Elliot
in what's not Julia Louie Dreyfus who's
the other one Andie MacDowell and they
see his corpse and it's the one moment
that's outside of Bill Murray's
perspective from that movie so it's
implied that like there were endless
timelines where things moved on without
him which is super messed up anyway
we're getting sidetracked on Groundhog
Day just because we love it I want to
ask you guys my takeaway is that this
mad avast it's like a metaphor for the
way the show uses Rick's suicidal
tendencies to trick us into feeling bad
for him do you guys think that Rick
deserves any of our sympathy really
mirror to hypocrisy in our both our
online culture and our social media and
even our day-to-day socializing like at
the end when that woman gives the
impassioned speech about
he deserved consequences but perhaps
we're to blame a little bit as well for
making a boy jump into a vat of acid
like the right jumping into the VAT of
acid is all of the people that just get
absolutely destroyed on Twitter Ferb
whether deservedly or not and like you
know there's so many examples the woman
who tweeted that awful thing about
getting AIDS in Africa and then came
back on a flight and then lost Wi-Fi
landed had lost her job had been
retweeted 150,000 times like that was an
absolutely disgusting thing for her to
tweet did her life need to be completely
destroyed permanently for it no and I
think like you know ultimately we come
around but it's like the the immediate
nature of like punishment has become
like we've really become a mob ruled mob
justice punishment system on Twitter
especially so I think Rick doesn't
deserve sympathy I think he deserves a
pause and and understanding that like he
is the profane core test version of like
what is a good point
interesting what do you think then no I
love the behind-the-scenes video because
it's really cool when you because they
put him out on YouTube but also if you
get the season pass on iTunes those just
immediately get uploaded as soon as the
episodes out there so I I did like the
point hey I did like what how they
talked about the lesson of this episode
that maybe sometimes he's a kid like he
maybe he dessert maybe more tea or other
younger people that might not know or
were you know or make mistakes maybe
they should be let off the hook but
that's clearly not what Rick's doing
Rick's just trying to be petty Rick's
being Rick and yeah I have no I have no
sympathy for him but it does it you guys
bring up a great point like reevaluating
all the times that you you're meant to
feel bad for Rick where either he feels
lonely in the universe or he doesn't
feel loved or you find like the facade
like cracks for a second and you think
you're getting past you like actually
maybe you're not maybe or nothing maybe
this is just this is him like
contemplating the whole like do-over
scenario yeah and for all we know he's
left universes millions of times we have
no idea he might just do this without
building a special device that resets it
and kills alternate versions of the
world
he might just literally be making the
conscious decision of of abandoning his
own mistakes
moving on from them so it makes it it
makes it a lot more complicated and
actually this episode made me think
about like that we haven't had like a
super deep episode yet this felt like it
with the whole interlude with him with
his romantic partner and I feel so bad
that we don't get she doesn't even get
to talk to him at the end of the episode
but and so like that's the closest we've
gotten it feels like this season two
getting to like a deeper moment to like
see behind the the comedy and the sci-fi
gobbledygook so I don't know I really
hope we had to confront that again
because we thought that like Rick was
this like sci-fi
intergalactic war veteran that's like
fighting for freedom or whatever it's
like maybe not he really might and like
I don't know maybe I'm overthinking it
which I usually do but like to me the
level of pettiness and commitment Rick
has just to prove his point and get
revenge on Morty feels like eric cartman
Scott tenorman must die episode like the
way he the way he like relishes and
Morty at the end having to come to his
side like yes this is the bat that feels
like hard to be like your tears you know
that's that's this is his in some ways
Rick's darkest moment and not just for
like the death he's caused but just for
like some of the pettiness of this point
it's it's pretty dark one thing that
interests me about this episode among
any things is one of my favorite
episodes was the fact that like Rick's
whole moral stance is that he's anti
time-travel but like we just saw three
episodes ago stepa sowed five they did a
whole Terminator style episode what do
you guys think is going on here do you
think this season was released out of
order and that originally that was gonna
be later they thought it was all gonna
be in the first half of the year or do
you think that was an exception for a
specific reason like snakes can do time
travel but Rick doesn't do time travel
yeah I'm Sudan I would be more like the
cat like the fact that people would be
confused or questioned if the season was
aired out of order would be a badge of
honor for them yeah oh did you are you
having trouble following timelines
why time travel is a stupid idea I think
I don't I don't know I mean obviously
you know especially with how chaotic do
the business side of it or the reality
is with how chaotic the world is right
now especially with production like that
things may have been screwed up they
might have even been saving some of
these episodes for later and they
realized they just had to put them out
like we need content yeah now and
there's nothing new being made really
suffer these great shows on new rock
star every week I don't know it feels
more like a a I like the mechanics that
they've set up in previous episodes like
this is like throwback to season 2
episode 1 right that's what time breaks
after they reset yeah yeah yeah and it
that's when they brought up the like the
brought mentioned time crystals and he
opened up like the whole like timeline
of the alternate alternate universes or
timelines that Marty's able to like kill
and then like snap over to it feels more
like they're using the rules that
they've set up to tell a time-based
story without it being time-travel so it
still feels like it's within like the
the timetable of the season like it
feels like everything's in order the way
it's supposed to be and I did like it
also I like to dig in ant-man the wasp
like if they can do it then would then
it's not worth doing so can we just
point out the fact that like there
wasn't technically time travel in
ant-man the wasp was Avengers endgame
but like they're so subtle enough
scalpel style with their dig that they
know that it was the post-credits scene
of ant-man and the wasp that technically
introduced time vortexes and the MCU
just with a throwaway line for Michelle
Pfeiffer that's the movie that gets the
heat which it's probably also yeah you
know the the co-writer the episodes
writing ant-man 3 Rick you know Dan
Harmon loves like throwing shade at
Marvel whenever he can because it's
popular and I just want to ask you guys
because this is like the central premise
of this episode what inspired the the
writers to write it it wasn't like the
time resetting it was just the weirdness
of a vat of acid that is uncovered and
how that's a trope like in DC Comics of
course with the Joker's origin but like
also in movies like why do we think
that's such a true
like why can't people cover their vats
of acid like a bubbling vat of green goo
is just such an appealing visual in an
action movie I fully agree also like we
finally like I feel like this like the
past five years we've finally moved out
of like the phloem and the slime and the
silly putty phase where like green
sticky gross fluids the slime thing I'm
like Nickelodeon we finally like started
to to like scoot away from that like a
little bit and I'm glad because I don't
understand why we got so enamored by all
that like the green ooze and TMNT or
lights like I don't / I mean I who did
what kid doesn't like a slamming on
Nickelodeon but like I don't there's
other ways to humiliate an adult for
cash there's rarely ever green goo yeah
we should point out that like the the
slime or the vat of acid doesn't
technically kill the Red Hood or the
Joker in the Tim Burton movie it just
Steve form some but it is an interesting
point that like it is so impractical to
have you know these huge drums of
uncovered liquid that like I love
there's rats running all around this
Factory for sure rat bones would be
floating around in that constantly it's
so unsanitary whatever you want to use
that acid for it doesn't make any sense
but I I do love it and I think ever
since of Breaking Bad we have not had a
truly good dissolving human flesh
plotline that I think that needs to be a
trope I think our world needs it a great
also that they instantly turn to bones I
love that it's like big it's
instantaneous that they jump in there
for five seconds that was five seconds
the horrible separate bus all all of
them's gone all of it all right well
that has been this week's episode of
Rick's
big thanks both to Sam basher and Tommy
Bechtel for joining me this week
especially the same for breaking down
those numbers for us it's great to get a
sense of the gravity of what Morty has
to live with now so funny a reminder to
all of you that you can get early audio
versions of the show just by subscribing
to explained wherever you get your
podcast you can follow me on social
media you can follow new rock stars
subscribe to this channel for more Rick
and Morty breakdowns our breakdown of
all the hidden animation details and the
jokes the Easter eggs that you miss this
episode it's coming next on the channel
there was some great like shout outs to
the Simpsons in South Park if you're
looking closely and we will close out
this week with our favorite joke from
the episode I'm acid proof all of you
all of you feels like that guy had other
stuff going on
[Music]